all right this should be a battle
you know actually changing my breathing
patterns right now like this you gotta
save you gotta pace yourself man
all right KP this is gonna be epic I
can't wait to see this start things off
with respect he's asking to try this
exponentially I respect that but I think
he's going anywhere bamboo I'm just
blocking all of this and right back
catch it going back there hey it's B
boom trying to get to LCQ but if you
ship one
splat at a time only one of these
players and we're gonna be seeing is
you're gonna be able to make it here
nice okay chop it away I like a little
flex with that childlike look at my
poles with cornish opportunity had an
opportunity to go and after the first
caper decided it's a simple dunk the
second one and get the easier more
proficient punished in that situation
now he gets up again from the side turn
their okay
teas in the right quick entry six they
come up off of that guard we have to see
any time you see that unblockable flame
coming out he just starts a you have to
make a decision now this is it but
walking our way to the very fickle wall
in this situation and as that reverse
forgot just sit is again just the
knowledge knowing where he's out on the
stage able to pull it off and look at
that bet the bar to get the extra on it
and that's thing you gotta remember if
six is the woman sitting to the lose yet
I can earlier but now he's coming out on
fire yeah a little bit of sauce sauce
insulin as pool I'm telling you man at
moments it was crazy and the person who
wins this is gonna stay on the stick
continuously so depending on what
happens it cigar loop beat up down some
more that was a great fend off are rich
sixes sole charge activation for pool
what however rich tix although we didn't
get as much as he wanted from the sole
charge he stayed on top of things that
there's a kid you could Pogo all you
want to hold this cave actually that's a
good point that you brought up to for
either one of these players that want to
win the turn but they're gonna have to
sit down and beat every single person
coming up save or the confirmation you
go spending a little bit more cash to
get that extension on the damage nice
block oh no I'm on the ground oh what's
up talk to be paradise oh yeah choppers
in Chiapas look at that he really just
poke them in the eye with the SONA all
talk to me boom talk to me nice now
don't just start wiggling doing one
wasn't prepared for 2-0 and I remember
this is losses city's final semi-final
so this is a two out of three set the
winners gonna earn themselves a date
with Seine and a three out of five
losses final set but both this time a a
far cry from what we saw now where this
bracket earlier
he's laughing what's going on someone
said something wrong oh no he's losing
his mind I think rich dicks big as well
that's the only think you would laugh
hysterically has something like that did
he really I mean what else why else
would you laugh like that well the
problem you're all about jokes here baby
he baby need tornado more like on the
screen it don't sell it anyways did it
go into Game two here and it's all the
same the maxi faster himself rich takes
and this stage ma'am are you know what
time it is
oh yeah I want to see someone go boom
trying to be able to come over to the
court and I don't think rich dicks wants
anything to do with that yes such a
massive life leading you up in and
control the entire way do the smart
thing
add a little patience please the clock
get the back throw very efficient I mean
right now he's been just doing very well
he's holding his ground and getting that
damage in place the thing is blue wall
man what is that that was nice red the
needle oh and again that's the second
time already in this match yeah the top
going under and what not quite enough
for the ringer let's see how rich six
approaches this time he stays close yeah
they're back saw anything to do with the
potential range oh we've seen plenty of
players lose aged nineteen ninety five
percent life Oh doesn't do anything else
but a little toe tap you gotta watch
your feet here and look at that rich six
is already threatening the tie of the
set they can do just thank you okay well
rich six has no no time for your games
this isn't funny to him and any stretch
of the imagination gets his approach
here but he's able to put a stop here
with the sole charge of his own keeps
his bike on the ground
and gets the follow up here to see what
he does how well then why must oh my
gosh my goodness you could save
follow-up you try to get the funny kid
not able to do it in time though alright
whom does have a slight life lead here
but rich chicks does have to meet her as
well this is gonna hurt look at this
damage yeah this time cast us out
instead of looking for we said
opportunity she puts it in the position
where oh man I thought he was trying to
fake him out there but look he's able to
take it still regardless and he's three
straight rounds that's a statement that
statement look at a piece Berg he's
hiding it slow but there's nothing
holding about one game apiece now this
is the decisive this is the heartbreaker
and now the Vaseline King is gonna have
to go deep into his thoughts and figure
it out you have a bevy of characters he
hit the character select screen big big
decision thinking here yeah this is the
final match so it's whoever you picked
you were stuck with these go to Rafael
he is going to Rafael he is not locked
in yet though take a knee et has now
alright the pink ruffles on deck do be
well look good play good as boom on his
last life st. his rich Stig's attorney
[Music]
just having fun with each other going
back and forth getting comfortable all
smiles but again I'm gonna tell you
after this mess almost gonna be sad is
they gonna be out of the tournament egg
thanks would it be surprised to be
tapped up hugged afterwards all of a
sudden out comes the yoshimitsu blade
again
am I getting ahead of myself all right
anyways there's the throw getting ahead
of herself as boom they're just standing
there and block not doing anything which
is like alright I'll come up with
punished fights here try this
every single time watch your legs though
a little clip tryna GI gonna lean back
hey do you rock away a lead back ok this
time eristic is gonna catch up you know
if you tell somebody to try this a
hundred times you know more than likely
they'll end up just doing it like damn
phone leave me alone all right I got
cheap but very evenly bad situation here
until that side steps just not arrange
for the throw and easy to practice it
because of that glass in that is
unfortunate
yeah that was super unfortunate imagine
training putting you in a situation but
you straight-up can't block yeah and
then starting the next round with a
lethal hit now you have no clothes and
you you're down like but somewhat argue
probably looks better whatever then
people could have that we trying to win
alright let's see let's see you do it
though pull it out he's supposed to have
it's a meter as well I like the pink
ruffles boat alright how about a loss to
the skies it all looks pretty when
you're doing it with one hand on the hip
wrap one of the most wagons characters
in the game and checking what a god
these guys reactions that knowledge and
the things these guys are comfortable
with you if these guys have played each
other so many times yeah you got to
think these guys no mix-up did that with
money that we're putting on that oh my
gosh oh look like a bait for hole but
you can't even beat a single hole rich
takes stop with a statement here and
look at that one round away
boom in trouble right I don't see out of
whole pack oh and look at that this is
big look at all that damage just from
that lethal hit right back at you let me
show you what a counter he can do
I'll put evening things up in this
situation there's that lethal hit at
big-time trouble one more situation will
get the job done from ridgid seektech
over home jump exact okay it's a tap on
snow we're talking a hand oh right back
at this mark stop there what you do own
the whip punish and that's gonna be it
that is the end of the run or coal-rich
states not gonna watch any charts so try
this look none of that you gave me the
spacing he gave me the beater and that
is it told him to sit down boomba vet he
knows what it is and it's gauntlets time
for rich steaks and he has earned myself
a date with saying yeah I got to give it
a little boom an impressive showing
throughout the entire tournament day
here in a Last Chance Qualifier fourth
play